Transcriber: Habip Bahçecioğlu
Gözden geçirme: Emel Çırakoğlu
İyi akşamlar herkese hoş geldiniz.
Öncelikle sizi 1998 yılına
götürmek istiyorum.
Aynanın karşısında poz verirken
hatırlıyorum kendimi.
Herkesin kendini ilk defa hatırladığı
bir an vardır.
Ben Jessika May, ilk defa 5 yaşındayken
Brezilya’da çiftlikte
ineklerin, köpeklerin, atların arasında,
aynanın karşısında poz verirken
hatırlıyorum kendimi.
Bu akşam
o küçük kızın hikayesinin Türkiye nasıl
geldiğinin, Türkçeyi nasıl öğrendiğimin
neden ve nasıl Türk vatandaşı olduğunu
sizlerle paylaşmaya çalışacağım.
Bu arada buradan çok güzel görüntü
görünüyorsunuz demek istedim ama
görmüyorum hiçbir şey.
Çok heyecanlıyım.
Heyecanlandığım zaman dilim dönmeyebilir,
kelimeleri doğru bir şekilde
söylemeyebilirim.
O yüzden şimdiden affedin.
Sağ olun.
Evet çiftlikteyim ben.
Artık manken olmak hayalim oldu.
Ben manken olacağım dedim ama manken
olabilmem için başka bir
şehire gitmem gerekiyordu.
Çünkü benim şehrim çok küçüktü
ve bu şekilde ailemden de
uzak kalmam gerekiyordu.
Tamam dedim.
Ailemden uzak kalmak benim için çok
büyük bir fedakarlık ama ben bunu
halledebilirim dedim.
Ben bir şekilde bunu yapabilirim dedim.
Çünkü onların için yapmak istiyorum
aslında kendi kendime söylerken.
Sonra tamam ben bunları hallediyorum
derken küçük bir problemim oldu.
Panik atağım başladı.
Okul servis şoförüm bizi hep evimizin
yakınında bırakıyordu.
Fakat bir fırtına gününde
evimize gelmek istemedi.
Çünkü evimizin yolu topraktı ve çamurdan
dolayı oraya girmek istemedi ve beni çok
uzakta bıraktı.
Dolayısıyla ben çok iyi hatırlıyorum ki
otobüsten indiğimde ayağımda böyle
bembeyaz ayakkabıları vardı.
Annem yeni aldığı ilk defa giydim
o fırtına kopuyor ve
ben ise ayakkabıları çıkardım.
Elime tuttum ve koşmaya başladım.
Koşarken şimşekler çakıyor, yıldırımlar
düşüyor ve ben böyle koşa koşa koşa koşa
derken çat diye çamurun içinde düştüm.
Her yerim çamur oldu, toprak yedim,
yüzüme gözüme girdi.
Ayakkabılarım zaten pislendi ve
böyle kaldım.
Çok çocuktum ama hatırlıyorum kaldım
ve dedim ki ″Ayağa kalk Jessica″
″Eve ulaşman lazım, eve gitmen lazım.″
Fırtına kopuyor ve eve gittiğimde tir tir
titriyordum ve ilk büyük panik atağımın
krizi o zaman başladı.
Ondan sonra zaten durmadı,
bitmedi bugüne kadar.
Sonra, ben işte zaman geçtikçe kendi
kendime soruyordum ben şimdi ailemden
nasıl uzak kalacağım?
Ya ben bir işin ortasında kriz yaşarsam?
Ya o koskoca şehrin ortasında tek başıma
iken kötü hissedersem ben ne yapacağım?
Zaman geçti, hep sorular soruyordum
işte düşünüyordum kendi kendime.
Ve 15 yaşındayken zor bir karar aldım.
Dedim ki deneyeceğim ben.
Yani sorularla, korkularla olmuyor bu iş.
Ben o şekilde Sao Paulo’ya taşınarak
manken olarak
çalışmaya başladım.
Sao Paulo’da ilk zamanlarında amcamın
evinde yaşadım ve
orada yaşarken küflü bir
bir merdiven altında uyuyordum.
Ve çok psikolojik şiddet gördüm.
Zaten panik ataklarım çok arttı o dönemde.
Ben dedim ki taşınıyorum buradan.
Derken işte zaman geçti.
İş ve okul devam ederken Sao Paulo’da
17 yaşında iken Çin'den bir iş teklifi
geldiğini öğrendim ve aynı gün de
üniversiteden %100 biyolojik bilimleri
için burs kazandığımı öğrendim.
Ben dedim ki ne yapacağım şimdi?
Dedim ki annemi arıyım, annem ne yapayım?
Annem dedi ki Jessica
hayalinin peşinden git.
Çünkü manken olarak belli bir yaşa kadar
çalışabilirsin ama üniversiteyi 50
yaşındayken de okuyabilirsin.
Annem 40 yaşındayken üniversiteye girdi.
Tamam dedim.
Telefonu kapattım.
Valizimi hazırlamaya başladım.
Sonra
Çin’e gitmeden birkaç saat önce öğrendim
ki seyahatim iptal edildi.
Çünkü 2011 yılında Japonya'da tsunami
yüzünden Çin ekonomisi çok kötü olunca
kimseyi götürmek istemediler.
Dolayısıyla ben Brezilya’da
çalışmaya devam ettim.
İki hafta sonra.
Yani o dönemde hatırlayın ki çok büyük
bir hayal kırıklığı yaşadım.
Çünkü yurtdışında çalışmak benim
için çok büyük bir basamaktı.
Ama çalışmaya devam ettim ve inanıyordum,
umut ediyordum.
İki hafta sonra Türkiye’den
bir reklam teklifi geldi ve
Türkiye maceram böylece başladı.
Sonra Türkiye'ye geldiğimde ben insanları
çok dikkatli bir şekilde gözledim.
Çok dikkatli bir şekilde dinledim, izledim
ve fark ettim ki Türkçe ve
İngilizce aynı anda öğrenmeye başladım.
İnsanlar bana şarkılar gösteriyorlardı,
deyimler anlatıyorlardı ve bir çekim
esnasında eşimle tanıştım.
Ama her şey çiçek değildi.
Çünkü ben ailemi çok özlüyordum
ve zaman zaman her şeyi
bırakıp vazgeçmeyi düşünüyordum.
Sonra o zaman erkek arkadaşım olan şimdi
eşim Hüseyin, işte bütün hissettiklerim,
düşündüklerim paylaşıyordum ve Hüseyin
bana çok büyük destek oldu.
Bugüne kadar Hüseyin bana dedi
ki bak Jessica, biri var.
7 yaşında iken babasını kaybetti.
7 yaşındayken okuldan alındı.
10 yaşındayken öğretmenden çok büyük bir
dayak yedi ve yüz kanlar içinde kaldı.
24 yaşındayken tutuklandı.
Sonra bir sürü kötü şey oldu.
37 yaşındayken böbrek hastası oldu ve
39 yaşındayken idam cezası aldı.
Sonra ben dedim ki ne oldu Hüseyin?
Hüseyin dedi,
ne oldu biliyor musun?
42 yaşında iken
Türkiye’nin Cumhurbaşkanı oldu.
O zaman ben Atatürk’le ilk defa tanıştım
ve bu hikayeyi hiçbir zaman unutmadım.
Çünkü başına bir sürü kötü şey gelen bir
insan nasıl böyle bir şey başardı?
Sonra ben Türkiye'de devam ettim.
Çünkü başka ülkelere gidecektim
çalışmak için.
Ama o kadar çok sevdim, o kadar aşık oldum
ki burada kalmaya karar verdim ve
Brezilya-Türkiye’nin arasında uçuyordum.
Bir süre sonra daha fazla televizyon
reklamı çekmeye başladım ve yönetmenler
bana sık sık söylemeye başladılar.
Bizce sen beyazperdede çok yakışacaksın.
Ekran seni çok seviyor.
Kamera seni çok seviyor.
Ya dizi ya da film yapalım.
O kadar çok duydum ki bunu.
Dedim ki
ben oyunculukla ilgili bir
şey denemek istiyorum.
Ve orada karar verdim.
Bunu söyledikten birkaç ay sonra bana bir
tarih dizisi dizisinden bir teklif geldi.
Beni 3 ay boyunca beklettiler.
Dediler ki biz seni istiyoruz.
Aradığımız kız sensin.
Seninle çalışacağız.
Kaşını, saçını, tenine kadar
hiçbir şey dokunma.
Ve üç ay boyunca ben sadece
onları bekledim.
Heyecan içinde.
Derken bir gün çok basit ve hızlı
bir şekilde aradılar ve dediler
ki başkasıyla anlaştık.
Ben hayal kırıklığına uğradım.
O kadar kötü oldum ki hiç unutmayacağım
3 ay boyunca sadece o karakteri yaşadım.
Yaşamak istedim.
Sonra ben depresyona girdim
o dönemde ve dedim ki
eşime ve menajerime
Ben Brezilya gidiyorum ailemin yanına.
Ve ama gitmeden önce menajerimin ofisine
uğradım ve dedim ki bakalım.
Bu süreçte bana oyunculukla
ilgili bir şey gelmezse
Ben Brezilya’ya temelli gidiyorum.
Orada ayağa kalktım.
Benim ayağa kalkma anım
oydu çünkü o zamanda.
Çünkü ben çok net hatırlıyorum.
İşte gelmezse gidiyorum ve
çok net bir şekilde çıktım.
Ofisinden ve Brezilya’ya gittim.
Brezilya'ya gittikten bir ay sonra bana
ilk işim olan Yeni Gelin projesi geldi ve
bir hafta sonra ben İstanbul'daydım.
Böylece benim oyunculuk kariyerim
resmi olarak başladı.
Ben bugüne kadar kendim için
hiçbir şey yapmadım.
Ne yaptıysam ailem için yaptım.
Kazandığım yaptıklarımın
her zaman onlar için.
Çünkü onları mutlu gördüğümde ben zaten
ödülümü aldım ve hiçbir zaman en iyisi
olsun ya da benim için en
büyük olsun demedim.
Ben sadece güneşin altındaki
yerime geçmek istedim.
Çünkü Brezilya’da bir deyimimiz var:
Güneşin altında herkesin
bir yeri vardır mutlaka.
Yani güneş herkese parlar.
Ve ben anladım ki biz bu dünyada
hepimiz yolcuyuz.
Ve bu yolculuğu yaparken
yani yolumuzda
yolumuzun sonundaki kurduğumuz o hayali
o büyük, ben büyük bir kırmızı
gül olarak görüyorum.
O kırmızı güle ulaştığınızda çok
mutlu olacağımızı düşünüyoruz.
Fakat o kırmızı gül ulaştığımızda
başka bir çiçek görüyoruz.
Daha büyük bir çiçek, daha büyük bir gül
görüyoruz ve ona ulaşmak istiyoruz ve bu
hiçbir zaman bitmiyor.
Sonra dedim ki mutluluk geçici
bir ruh halidir.
Yani mutluluk aslında yolculuğun
ta kendisidir.
Ve anladım ki dikkat etmemiz
gereken bir şey var.
Yani bu yolda iken o kırmızı güle ulaşmaya
çalışırken ayağınızın altındaki
kır çiçekleri, papatyaları, laleleri
eze eze gidebiliyoruz.
Halbuki seni mutlu edecek aslında
ayağının altındaki
o minik çiçekler olabilir.
Lütfen bunu hiçbir zaman unutmayın.
Çok teşekkür ederim.